the fathers of two American teenagers
accused of killing an Italian police
officer are in Rome this morning
Gabriel Natali yourthe and Finnegan
elder are accused of stabbing an Italian
officer to death they could face life in
prison if convicted Seth Doane is
outside the prison in Rome where the
teens are being held Seth what's the
scene like there this is the visitors
entrance to the prison you can see all
of the press gathered around right now
mr. elder is inside there visiting with
his son that means now that both fathers
have visited with their sons and we
understand both mothers are on their way
here to Italy to do the same now
according to prison rules family members
are allowed one hour once a week to go
inside they're allowed to extra bonus
hours at some point during the month and
this morning when mr. elder arrived he
was carrying a small bag which appeared
to have clothing inside it and his face
looked quite grim swarmed by media
Finnegan elders father
Ethan arrived at the prison this morning
saying nothing his son is confessed
investigators say - killing Carabinieri
officer Mario Churchill Arreaga
[Music]
who is stabbed 11 times following a
botched drug deal and extortion attempt
allegedly carried out by elder in his
former schoolmate Gabriel Natalia
police say elder stabbed the officer
with this seven inch long military-grade
knife which he brought from the us a
photo apparently posted on social media
and widely circulated shows elder posing
with a knife both teenagers had been
drinking on the night of the killing
according to police and at least one had
also been doing drugs the Carabinieri
officer forgot his service weapon early
Friday morning when he was called to
investigate that alleged extortion
attempt in which police say the teens
tried to get money and cocaine in
exchange for a bag they'd stolen Natali
your father visited him in prison
Wednesday rioting afterward my meeting
with Gabriel was emotional and hard for
both of us adding Gabriel never imagined
there would be a confrontation and did
not know his friend was armed outside
the prison this morning at a Labor's
lawyer told us his client is not -
Geronimo - bravado very young and very
emotionally stressed authorities say
both teens are responsible for the
killing and Italy someone can be charged
for murder if they were involved
regardless of whether the person carried
out the slaying the Tali Earths lawyer
told CBS News that when he visited his
client in prison earlier this week the
teen cried the entire time Tony still a
lot of questions there Seth Doane for us
in Rome said thank you very much